president-elect joe biden blames the
trump administration for the slow pace
of vaccinating americans and yesterday
mr biden made a promise
vaccinate 100 million americans in the
first
100 days of his term now the current
treasury secretary says the government
is starting to send out those
first six hundred dollar covet relief
checks but a bill to boost those
payments to two thousand dollars
is on hold in the u s senate paul reed
has more
president-elect joe biden blasted the
trump administration tuesday for
falling far short on its promise to get
americans vaccinated
the effort to distribute and administer
the vaccine is not progressing as it
should
administration officials have repeatedly
predicted tens of millions would receive
vaccine doses by the end of 2020.
20 million americans could be vaccinated
just before the end of this month in
december but according to the centers
for disease control
just over 2 million doses have been
administered and distribution of the
vaccine
across the country is lagging the pace
of the vaccination program is moving now
as it if he continues to move as it is
now it's going to take years not months
to vaccinate the american people
the president hit back saying it's up to
states to handle distribution of the
vaccines once delivered
while slamming mr biden's record during
the swine flu epidemic in 2009
do we turn our backs on struggling
working families
or do we respond to their pain and with
just
days left until congress ends its term
to two thousand dollars the president
has aligned himself with democrats in a
fiery debate in the senate tuesday
over larger covid relief checks even
president trump supports two thousand
dollar checks
in a sign of the president's dwindling
power senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell appears
unmoved on tuesday he blocked two
attempts by democrats to advance a house
bill
the motion to reconsider that would
deliver those larger payments
it's their objection to the modification
object
objection is heard
senators david perdue and kelly lefler
both say they support the president's
push for larger stimulus payments
the two georgia lawmakers both face a
critical runoff next week that will
determine control of the u.s senate
president trump has previously announced
he'll head to the state to campaign on
their behalf
and this morning president-elect joe
biden announced he will head to atlanta
on the same day to drum up support for
their democratic rivals
adriana paula thank you